Well, let's see. The first thing I want to know if how much time the ball spends in the air.
That's governed entirely by its vertical motion.
Remember this equation? Let's use that.
Though maybe I should write Δy instead of Δx to emphasize this is vertical motion.
I know that Δy, the total distance the ball moves, is just h,
and the ball starts at rest, so I can ignore this term.
That just leaves me with this--½gt².
Remember, instead of a I wrote g, the acceleration of gravity.
That tells me the time the ball spends in the air
is twice the height of g and the square root of that.
When you plug in 1.2 for h and 10 for g you get a value of 0.49 sec.
Okay, so that's how long the ball spends in the air.
Now let's analyze the horizontal component of motion.
That's governed entirely by the electric force.
Remember, the electric force is equal to qE,
which in this case would be 0.1 * 100 or 10 N.
That 10 N force is causing an acceleration.
We know that F = ma, so 10 N is equal to mass the acceleration in the x direction
I should say, because we're just looking at that component motion for now.
Solving this, I find that this x acceleration is equal to 10 divided by the mass.
When I plug in 8 kg, I find that's equal to 1.25 m/s².
Well, now I can use my good friend--Δx is equal to initial velocity times time,
but there's no initial velocity, so I'll ignore that,
plus ½a--that's this a--times the time squared.
The time we're going to use is that 0.49 sec we found before.
That gives me distance of 0.15 m.
Actually, if this is was 1.2 m, it only moved about to here. Good work.